hey I have a question for you do you
think I'd be any good uh as a you know
Rider of horses as a cowboy do you think
I'd do you think i' and be honest Bryce
we know each other well enough uh how do
you think I'd do out on the trail um I
think if somebody invited you to go
rioting you would show up dressed as
howdy Duty yeah and you would
correct i' have a bandana and really
starched like my jeans would have a
crease my would be real starched uh and
I'd have a hat that had never like had
no dust on it like a and it was way too
big for my
head yeah and then you would complain
about chaing because everything's so
starched and yeah you'd be you'd be
riding a horse like Robert dowy Jr in uh
oh goodness what's that movie Bad horse
rider Sherlock Sherlock Holmes oh does
he sitting there just oh yes he that's
right he's not a good yes in one of the
Sherlock Holmes movies he's on a horse
and he's not good at it
um interesting uh I I have a problem and
Sona has worked for me for a long time
and she can attest to this I have no
flesh at all on my bottom there's just
nothing there I'm just a pelvis like a
lab skeleton pelvis so if I was riding a
horse I think I'd be in a lot of pain
unless can you put a cushion down what
can you put on the saddle and and not be
made fun
of uh nothing um if you put something on
there you will get made fun
of men and women everyone what if no one
could see it what if I just coated it
with a thick gel a clear gel that was
cushiony and uh and also had certain
medicinal properties maybe numbing the
nerves of the ass so that I didn't pad
inside your pants so you have like a big
old booty but it's real soft yes stuff
stuff your pants well I do that but you
mean in the
back okay so
so Bryce just move it to the back yeah
fine yeah yeah just take what's in the
front and put it in the back yeah okay
and then there's just a huge concave
space in the front oh that's real funny
that's real
funny just move the old zucchini to the
back so
Bryce um I think I do okay I'm I'm I'm
pretty adaptable and I think I'd be a
good cowboy I know that i' yes would my
ass get sore it would but I'm a lot of
fun out on the trail I think I'd have
good stories around the campfire at
night is there a campfire at night
absolutely there's campfire and coffee
regardless if you stop at midnight
you're you're making a pot of coffee
well I can't do that I'll be up all
night so um can do you guys ever make
decaf Cowboys
don't yeah no that's that's we literally
pour grounds into a pot of boiling water
and then drink it okay I have a I'm
going to bring with me a machine that's
rather large my God that decaffeinate
the coffee it's an $88,000 Swiss machine
um and that's going to have to be pulled
by six horses I hope that's okay fast if
you were a cowboy no I mean probably I
think you'd be left behind left
behind yes hey but what if the other
Cowboys start to go you know I like this
decaf coffee let's keep this Conan guy
and his Swiss machine around just put a
cowboy hat on the coffee maker like it's
like a robot cck Cowboy that came along
for the ride every Christmas season it's
the same thing demands for more podcast
episode comes in and we've got to meet
those demands we got to mail out those
podcasts we got to get them in the mail
well guess what with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that Holiday Rush you
know what I'm saying no remember last
year when we were stuffing podcast into
envelopes and licking them and putting
on the stamps it was crazy in here no
more not with stamps.com they even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to get started cuz whenever I
go to mail stuff out I'm like where's my
scale well they got the scale ready
there for you now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a 4-we trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term Comm or
contracts just go to stamps.com Conan I
have a lot of admiration for Cowboys and
well cow folk in general you know I I do
it's part of the Great American Dream
nothing looks cooler than being on a
horse I think and uh and no and pulling
up somewhere you know clapping up and
then just jumping off the horse and
tying it up to a post and going inside
and having a shot of whiskey that's
something I grew up watching all the
time on television and it never happened
well Bryce actually has a really good
question for you regarding this so Bryce
do you want to ask your question yeah
ask my question
Bryce yeah what uh what what would your
nickname be what what would your cowboy
nickname be on the
trail Wow Let's see Sharp
ass old sharp ass he's got an ass like a
meat cleaver just bone you know just
bone you could you can slice slice ham
on that guy's ass you know you don't you
wouldn't want to but you could yeah old
sharp ass that call me here comes sharp
ass hey sharp ass what's up oh not much
I was just here with my $88,000 machine
decaffeinating these
beans what's up with you
guys what do you think pretty sure they
come decaffinated
yeah okay yeah what you the machine
decaffeinate the beans yeah it's very
expensive machine and then you just have
a pile of beans you could just bring
decaf beans
oh I already bought this machine oh man
you got
it no I can't cuz I had the wheels that
were on it taken off and ones that were
appropriate for the trail put on cuz I
was anticipating this conversation this
is such a bad idea yeah it's got shock
absorbers uh it's got a little cow
catcher oh you spruced it up too Bru it
up it's got an incredible
suspension I've put over $35,000 into
this $8,000 machine oh my God Conan
that's so unnecessary jeez well sharp
ass to
you okay uh Bryce I think that uh I'd be
a pretty good cowboy and i' and um I'd
like it I would really like it I would I
would love to go out on a ride I really
would what's the longest ride you guys
go out
for uh The Longest Ride I've been on was
11 days and over you know probably
around like 120 to 150 miles wow that is
so cool do you think we could arrange it
so we're sort of near a Four Seasons
Hotel oh man no but you know what I mean
that's kind of what we're trying to
avoid but um we could
probably circles around the block yeah
what I'm saying is we ride but then I
disappear for I don't know 15 18 hours
at a time and I come back and you smell
massage oil and I've had an incredible
cob salad just
incredible uh yeah I guess I guess we
could uh figure that out or you could
just have the four seasons of being
outside and deal with
yeah sharp okay I don't know I don't
know Bryce there a certain way I like
things you know I like to be able to
just pick up the phone and order the
food and it comes so I guess that's part
of I mean you could bring Sona and Matt
with you and then they could just take
care of you hold on there Bryce look I
was interested in you said that sounded
fun but uh I don't cater to Old sharpz
here yeah we'll be with you guys and
then when he leaves we give every
everyone the signal and we just keep
going and that way he'll never find just
so you know Sona was my assistant for
like 15 years and didn't take care of me
then yeah so why would she on on the
trail you know that's not going to
happen that's true an assistant so then
that assistant would do things yeah well
his name is David hopping and he does do
things yeah incredible sorry taught him
everything he knows I don't think so
anyway AR what kind of horse would you
put Conan on like a Spirited One a tame
one a
oh it would absolutely have to be you
know a a 4AGE horse like a little kid's
horse it just it it' have to be
something that wouldn't blow up or
anything shortz and Egger's little
miniature pony Chelly Chelly I want one
more your knees are like all the way up
to your face I want one where you you
have to put quarters in and it gently
rocks
me